horror [ __ ] is that what that's like
no uh oh the movie that was a good movie
yeah that word
is something houses and [ __ ] it's not a
house where people are killed yeah like
a haunted house yeah
that was based off a true story oh it is
is it really
yeah that house has been for sale it was
the story of it the dad killed the
family
crazy said the spirits told him to kill
his family killed my family
very similar premise to the shining
where it's like somebody goes crazy in
the family
kills everybody that's a true story or
based off true events no no true story
well it's uh you know everything's based
off events but in the early morning
hours of november
13 1974 a man named ronald defeo
jr shot and killed his mother father
four siblings while they slept in their
suburban home
uh emilyville knew new york defeat was
convicted for murders and remains
incarcerated today
wow he's still uh oh so the he blamed it
out of the house
he blamed on voices you can buy the
house the house let me see the house
it looks oh you know why they gotta why
they gotta why they gotta put it
black and white they literally have to
do with that you have to
you know what i mean show me good please
sketches scare the [ __ ] out of me
really says they purchased the home for
80 grand it has to be in 1978
74 yeah 13 months later there you go so
how much now but now it's for sale again
but like the uh we talked about this the
mansion the house is where the murders
happened were for sale
and there's one los feliz which is super
haunted that just went for sale
yeah wait how much is that amityville
horror house
they said 8 000 right back then oh back
then i don't know how much you said 72
000 back there do you think
so those go up in prices because it's
like this has this thing
i don't know like based off a house like
that some of them are tough to sell like
that one that really hot it's like the
most haunted house in l.a
los filas it's like they're having
trouble selling it yeah
it's a hard sell but i feel like people
would only want to go and stay for a
couple days like an airbnb unless you're
on the
tears and [ __ ] the haunted tours every
halloween it's lit as [ __ ]
and people always passing by your house
and [ __ ] yeah my house drives by that
manson house i don't know
what's that yeah
see they don't have to do these pictures
but they're just 850 000 now
what the hell oh that's how much oh [ __ ]
he's they said ultra low play
and oh looks like it's haunted do they
have pictures of the inside
probably who the [ __ ] is buying that
house no one i would never do that
no one no one even spared anything like
that do i believe it
like evil spirits no you don't
you seem like you do i just shook my
head no we went like this
paranormal activity did you watch it
yeah the first one [ __ ] me up
i thought it was really actually after
that the uh the other ones weren't as
good yeah yeah it just got repetitive
for me but that first one
dawg i'm older than you guys but when
the blair witch project came out and
they watched that when their marketing
came out said this is real footage
ghosts and [ __ ] me and my friends wait
in line i forget at fox theater
in denver colorado there was a long line
we got in there i was
so [ __ ] scared oh i was because i
thought we all thought it was real yeah
everyone was just the marketing was
pretty good you know
all the actors that they couldn't like
reach out to people once the movie
premiered
to make it seem like it was they did
really good with nobody could ever do
something like that again
no yeah because now like you know but at
the time it was like
everyone's lying like damn you know this
is really like that's real like
you thought you were watching so i went
in and you're just like holy [ __ ]
then we got out of there and everyone's
uh dude i said with the lights on for
days
yeah and then like weeks went by and so
i was like you know that shit's fake
right
and then they printed article that's
fake you watch that [ __ ] when you know
it's fake
it's the worst movie ever it's
so terrible yeah i haven't seen it
literally the worst movie ever made yeah
it's only cool if it's if you think it's
real it's so bad
damn it's so [ __ ] bad really really
watch it is it on like amazon
it probably is it's on youtube dude
youtube it's a kind of writer
it's a complete waste of your time they
did a modern one too
like more recently last year or two they
have a new blair witch project
oh they made a new one i mean what do
you know somebody give up yeah
yeah they're like maybe we can get them
again
they [ __ ] got me my friends man we
were [ __ ]
terrified the one that yeah the movie
that [ __ ] me up the most is
1999 more recent uh was
uh the strangers that i think strangers
is good yeah the people with the masks
yeah
with uh to me that's more scary than
like what's the daughter's name
oh live tyler live tile yeah yeah
yeah that that's because that [ __ ]
actually really goes down that's the
[ __ ] that scares me
not this like vacancy you ever seen that
they're chilling right they're chilling
and uh he's like oh there's a vcr there
he goes there's a [ __ ] vhs in there
yeah
and clicks it and it shows of like a
couple in the room getting murdered
and he's watching he's like what the
[ __ ] is this thing he's looking he's
like
he looks at the light he's like this
looks like this light it looks like
that's this [ __ ] room and then they
start [ __ ] with them it's nuts
how old is this bro this [ __ ] came on
2000 and
2007 seven 2007 yeah and that one got
you pretty good
oh i went to the movie murder and real
stuff i just i don't enjoy that stuff
yeah because that [ __ ] really happens i
just too close to home yeah it's just
i was ever since you saw that weekend
video i saw i was i was 16. how about
that
world star video you saw me watching at
the airport that russian dude slapped
i'm just slapping
just slapping it it was like some weird
religious thing but it had no kind of
stuff [ __ ] up or something but he was
slapping this woman yeah
so [ __ ] hard he would speak and point
at people and uh
it was like he was doing it but it
wasn't just her i mean they only showed
him slapping her but like it was
like a row of people i've never seen
somebody get slapped so hard in my life
and not getting knocked out
like dug the goose but he was like like
she messed up and he's like proven a
point yeah he was like
yeah and he was like sermon and then
like he was slapping the [ __ ] out of her
when i get off stage at the lab factory
right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what this from a bunch of other comics
i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son